beyond that scandal that's a pretty big
one but the second biggest one
of 2020. the democratic candidate for
president
is barely conscious and we're going to
see that on display tonight at the
debate
there's going to be the big debate
donald trump and joe biden
joe biden on msnbc very friendly tv
station just a few days ago
he's chatting with the anchor there and
he's making a strong point about what a
terrible
trump has done on a certain aspect of
legislation except he can't remember the
name of the legislation and
very sadly the anchor has to just give
him the answer at the end
for example the paycheck protection act
you know one percent of the money's gone
out
one percent one percent of the uh the
that's not the paycheck the the um uh
the uh the bill for a small for major
infrastructure
may seem lenny one percent's gone out
why isn't that lady running for
president that lady obviously has a much
clearer grasp
on the policy issues than joe biden does
he doesn't even he's invading against
this one
law and then turns out oh wait a second
it's he's actually thinking about the
other law
very sad very pathetic i know we don't
want to set expectations too low for the
debate tonight but the expectations
already set low joe biden set them
so what's going to happen i still think
there's a chance that they find some way
to to game the system tonight donald
trump has called for joe biden
to take a drug test before he goes out
there on the stage tonight
that's probably not a serious suggestion
he just wants to set it in people's
minds that joe biden is taking
performance-enhancing drugs which
i wouldn't be surprised if he is and
that's kind of trump's mo
is to is just set these insinuations so
people can see it even if he doesn't get
the uh the concession that he's looking
for i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]